MORGAN MCLEAN: Hi, and
welcome to our session
Ops 203, OpenTelemetry
and observability
at Shopify, Splunk, and Google.
My name is Morgan McClean.
I'm a product manager at Google.
I primarily focus on
OpenTelemetry as well as
a number of our ops
management products,
including Cloud Monitoring
and Cloud Logging.
STEVE FLANDERS: And
hi, I'm Steve Flanders.
I'm a director of
engineering at Splunk
working on our observability
getting data in strategy.
I'm an OpenTelemetry
collector approver.
MORGAN MCLEAN: We have
a packed agenda today,
and we're going to have
interesting information
for those who are familiar
of OpenTelemetry and those
who are not.
We'll begin with an
introduction to the project--
what OpenTelemetry is and
what the project includes.
Then we'll move on
to OpenTelemetry
and how it fits into the
broader field of observability.
After that, we will
show getting started
guides and examples of how
you can use OpenTelemetry.
And finally, we'll have
stories of companies
that make use of OpenTelemetry
in their production services
today.
OpenTelemetry has a number
of different components,
and I'm going to start from
the most basic ones all
the way to the core
implementations
that customers are using
today in production.
To start with, we have
the specification.
The specification is, in many
ways, the core of the project.
It defines the different
signals and different data types
that you can use to
capture telemetry
from your application.
For example, there's
a specification
for metrics that defines
what a metric is,
what a metric can capture,
and how you interact with it.
Similarly, there are
specifications for traces,
resources, and logs.
Keep in mind that the log
specification is relatively new
compared to the others,
so it's still incubating.
Next we have a data model.
The data model describes
how actual APIs
and how your code will
interact with this data,
and how a metric, or trace,
or log, or other component
is actually described
to a computer system.
Next we have API services.
These are the different ways
that your code will interact
with the data model in order
to capture correct telemetry
from your application.
These API services
include instrumentation,
which allow you to go and
create a metric for something
like an RPC call, or to
define what a trace will look
like when you're capturing
it from a certain source;
configuration, which
allow you to interact
with other parts of the
OpenTelemetry APIs and SDKs,
like sampling for example;
and finally, there's
an API for exporters.
Exporters are how we send
data from an OpenTelemetry
SDK or other
OpenTelemetry resource
to other back end components.
These back end components might
be the OpenTelemetry collector,
which is an agent.
We'll get to what
that is in a moment.
They can do that through
the standard OpenTelemetry
interchange protocol, or
you can use an exporter
to send data directly to the
back end like Google Cloud
Ops or Splunk.
Finally, we also defined
semantic conventions.
These semantic
conventions are not
so much rules for the
machine, but rules
for people who are defining
instrumentation or capturing
data from their applications.
An example of a
semantic convention
would be how to create a metric
for HTTP latency or HTTP QPS.
It would include the tags
that you're generally
expected to add there,
and the metric names
that you would generate.
The same is true for tracing.
The next level up
in OpenTelemetry
is the actual APIs and SDKs.
We have one API and
SDK per language,
so there are no
competing implementations
and all effort is driven behind
that single implementation
for language.
OpenTelemetry, as mentioned,
has the standard SDKs.
Because we've APIs, you can also
go ahead an SDK of your own.
As far as I know I
don't think anyone is,
but it's totally available
for vendors or anyone else
to go to find their own SDK.
And the APIs allow you to go
use the API surfaces that I
described before to actually
go and write instrumentation
or to interact with
the SDKs themselves.
The SDKs contain
logic for things
like sampling, or creating a
trace, or creating a metric,
and so we generally
recommend that people
use the standard SDKs.
That seems to be what most
the community is doing.
Next we have the collector.
This is an optional component.
The collector runs as an agent.
So whereas the SDKs you would
link them to your application
to go capture traces and
metrics, the collector
you would instead run
on the operating system.
The collector generally can't
capture traces and metrics
directly from your application.
Those have to be done
through the SDKs.
But it can be used as
a processor or proxy
that you send that
data to before it gets
exported to your
final destination,
and it makes things like
configuration a little easier,
and it makes just a generally
cleaner, easier export path
to send data to your
back end of choice.
The collector can also
capture system metrics.
So metrics from places where
you can't use the API and SDK.
Think of memory consumption
or disc consumption.
You can do this for
Windows and Linux.
And the collector can
be deployed as an agent
on a particular
operating system--
in that case you also get the
system metrics if you want
them--
or it can be
deployed as a service
so that you can access it and
send data over the network.
The collector also
contains receivers
for metrics from Prometheus
and traces captured
from Zipkin or Jaeger clients.
There's also some
new components that
have been added to
OpenTelemetry fairly recently.
These are auto instrumentation
agents for Java, Python,
and JavaScript, and we're adding
some other languages soon.
These will take some of
the functionality you would
normally get in the SDK, like
capturing traces from an app,
and they are able to
perform that functionality
without having to link to your
application and rebuild it.
Now, they're not as
generally useful as the SDKs.
The benefit of the SDKs is you
can go to find a custom metric,
or make changes to
trace annotations,
or use the any of the APIs
natively that you want to.
You can't do that with the
auto instrumentation agent.
But if you have an
application that
is difficult to
recompile or rebuild,
or one that you don't
have the source code to,
the auto instrumentation
agent is a great choice.
OpenTelemetry entered
beta in March.
This is a big effort
by the community,
and we're incredibly proud of
the accomplishments we've had.
And this is why you see some
firms and some organizations
already using some OpenTelemetry
components in production
systems.
Specifically, the
March beta included
the Java, Python, JavaScript,
and Go SDKs, as well as
the Erlang SDK.
And I think the .net SDK is
about to hit beta or already
just has.
The beta also included
the collector.
The beta was very focused
on tracing functionality
and also included
metrics functionality.
We're targeting a GA
later this autumn.
Prior to the GA we'll have
several release candidates
coming up that will
be pre-GA versions.
And eventually once we're
very satisfied with one,
we'll declare that as
the final GA version.
Expect those release
candidates to start rolling out
later this summer and
the GA to take place then
later this year.
STEVE FLANDERS:
OK, so let's talk
about observability,
specifically in the context
of OpenTelemetry.
As Morgan mentioned,
there's a specification
which is basically
the foundational part
of the OpenTelemetry project.
This specification can
be data source specific.
So for example, there are
specifications for both traces
and metrics, and inside
each of those specifications
is some rich information
about how you actually
define the information--
the telemetry
that you're trying to admit.
In the case of traces
this includes the spans
and different attributes that
are attached to those spans.
In the case of metrics, you
have labels and the ways
you actually account for
the different metrics
that you care about
in your environment.
You can actually
drill into these.
They're all on the
GitHub repository
if you're interested in learning
more information about them.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Next
we have resources.
So as the slide describes,
every OpenTelemetry signal
is tied to a resource.
And if you think about
this, this makes sense.
If you're capturing metrics
from your application or traces
from your application, they're
not particularly useful
unless you know
where each metric
or where each span of a
trace actually came from.
There's different levels
to these resources.
You can go as low level as
the actual information that
describes the actual machine
that a metric or trace came
from all the way up to
higher level concepts
like services, or
Kubernetes containers,
or deployments from which
you're capturing this data.
STEVE FLANDERS:
Semantic conventions
are also extremely powerful.
The idea is, how do
I actually define
this thing that I'm calling?
Like for example, if
I have a REST endpoint
or I'm calling a database,
if there was a way
to just normalize that
information so it didn't matter
which vendor or back end
I'm sending my data to,
I could still query it
out in a unique way,
that'd be extremely powerful.
And that's exactly what
semantic conventions try to do.
By offering a standard way
of actually instrumenting it,
you can then leverage any
back end of your choice
in order to query the data out
and get the insights that you
care about.
True observability.
Now in the case of tracing,
context propagation
is probably one of the
most fundamental pieces.
It's basically how you
glue everything together.
So when you have your
service to service calls,
you're actually passing
context between those calls.
You actually see
a representation
of this on the right hand side.
This is actually from
the Jaeger documentation.
Basically, you call
into a service,
and you generate context.
You then pass that
context as you
make other calls to
downstream services
within your environment.
That context can also be
shared within the application
for functional level calls.
But this context
propagation concept
actually goes beyond
distributed tracing.
For example, I probably
want to share metadata
between my different
data sources,
and I can do that through
the correlation context
specification information.
In addition, I need a
way to actually share
that between my APIs and
SDKs, and the propagators
data's is how we do that in
the OpenTelemetry project.
There are links to all
this information if you're
really interested in
learning the specifics of it,
but this is really
the magic that
glues all the information
together and makes it extremely
useful when you want to actually
query out and get insights
from them.
So let's talk a little
bit about getting started
with the OpenTelemetry project.
The easiest way to do
that is to really start
talking about the architecture.
So you can see here
we have a host.
There's an application running
on it, and maybe we have one
or even multiple back ends
we want to send our data to.
How do we get started
with OpenTelemetry?
Well, first we're going
to go ahead and deploy
the OpenTelemetry
collector as an agent.
The reason why we do
this is kind of twofold.
One is it can go ahead and
grab the system metrics for you
automatically and send
that to the back end
or back ends of your choice.
Secondarily, if I actually
leverage the OpenTelemetry
collector as an agent with the
OpenTelemetry client libraries,
then it's automatically
configured for me thanks
to the use of the OTLP
protocol that is built
into the OpenTelemetry project.
So if I deploy the OpenTelemetry
client library and an agent
is already running there,
the traffic will be received,
both metrics and
traces, eventually logs,
and all that data can
then be sent to one
or more back ends based
on configuration rules
that I write in the
collector itself.
This provides flexibility
and also offloads
some of the responsibility
from the application itself--
things like buffering, and
retry, encryption, compression.
All that can actually be
offloaded from the application,
which would consume resources
and actually be handled
in a single language-- in
the case of the collector,
it is Go--
one way and be handled
across my entire fleet.
Another deployment
architecture is actually
to have the collector running
as a standalone service.
That would be typically in the
same data center or region.
I would deploy one or more
of these collector instances,
and usually it's the agent that
will forward to the collector.
Now, the idea here
is maybe I want
to limit the number
of egress points
I have in my environment.
So I don't want all the
agents to talk to the internet
to send to my
vendors' back ends.
Maybe I want to
consolidate the API keys.
Maybe I want bigger
buffer or retry queues,
and so I can offload this
to a set of collectors
that I can scale up
or out as needed.
There are different
use cases for this.
Another one would
be around tracing.
Maybe I want to do
tail based sampling.
That typically doesn't
follow an agent model.
You typically need
standalone collectors
in order to achieve that, and
the OpenTelemetry collector
is actually a single
binary that can
be deployed as either an agent
or as a standalone service
and is very configurable
depending on your use cases.
So next I want to talk
about auto instrumentation.
Because if you've never got
started with instrumentation
before, it may seem like a
lot to actually get going.
And really,
OpenTelemetry's trying
to make this be as
easy as possible.
And then later on, you can
get to manual instrumentation
if you want to add your own
custom metric or tracing
information, your own
metadata, and enhance what's
available out of the box.
The idea with auto
instrumentation
is it's basically
runtime parameter changes
to your application,
not code changes.
So it's very easy
to get started.
Here's an example of
a Java application.
Let's say I have a Java
call to a JAR-- the JAR
that I've written that
runs my application.
All I need to do is go ahead and
define a Java agent parameter
and point to the OpenTelemetry
Java agent all JAR file.
In addition here,
I've gone ahead
and set an environmental
variable which
will set the service name.
So I know what this
service actually is
and how it will be
represented in the back end
that I'm forwarding
that traffic to.
That's it.
I then just fire
up my application,
and I can go ahead and get
rich trace data automatically
for any supported library.
And there is broad
support for this today.
Here's an example,
in the case of Java,
of all the different
libraries and versions
that are supported.
Now, this slide is probably
already out of date
because new ones are being
added every single day, so
go ahead and take a look at
this and feel free to contribute
additional ones.
But it provides broad
support and really can
get you started with
distributed tracing information
with little
development involvement
in order to get you started.
Now with that, I'd
like to show you
a demo of how you can
actually get started
with both the OpenTelemetry
collector and with Java
auto instrumentation.
OK, let's go ahead and fire
up the demo application.
While it starts up here, I'll
explain to you what's going on.
First, we're going to be
leveraging the Spring Pet
Clinic micro services
example application.
It's all based on
Java, and it's actually
multiple different
microservices that
communicate with one another.
As you can see,
they have a picture
on the repository
on what it looks
like from an
architectural perspective,
and the applications
are actually
not instrumented by default.
So our goal here is going to be
to add OpenTelemetry Java auto
instrumentation to the
Java microservices,
and to have them report to an
OpenTelemetry collector which
can then send to the back end
or back ends of your choice.
So what I've done
is I've actually
modified this repository.
I've added a
collector.yaml which
we'll go ahead and define
how we want the OpenTelemetry
collector to be configured.
In this case, I'm
basically just accepting
over the OTLP
protocol and defining
an endpoint where I can
actually send traffic
to a Zipkin server.
And this only needs
to be defined once.
In addition, basically how that
Spring Pet Clinic microservices
example app works is through
a Docker compose file.
So each of the microservices is
a different Docker container.
I've gone ahead and made
the following modification.
Basically, I've enabled the Java
agent runtime parameter, which
you pass first right
after the Java commands,
and I'm pointing it to
the OpenTelemetry Java
agent all JAR file.
And then I am defining
a service name
via an environmental variable.
So in this case, we have
the discovery service,
and I've repeated that for
every single microservice that's
in the Docker compose.
You'll see customers,
and visits, and vets.
Finally, I have defined
an OpenTelemetry collector
that actually gets
spun up as well
so that these
microservices can all
report to a locally running
OpenTelemetry collector
that uses the collector.yaml
file that I just showed.
For each of the microservices
we have a Docker file,
and in that Docker file we will
go ahead and get the JAR file
from the OpenTelemetry project
so that we can embed it
at runtime as a
parameter and have
it do byte code manipulation
of our application.
So that's about it.
And then what ends up happening
is this microservices app
gets fired up and
starts reporting traffic
to an OpenTelemetry collector.
You can actually
see here log lines
of different spans already
being recorded into the system.
So just by firing it
up, we haven't even
accessed the UI yet.
You can see that data is
being generated and being sent
to the back ends of my choice.
So I will go ahead and sort
out the pet clinic application.
You can see it's here.
We can go ahead and look
at, let's say, any owners
that are in the system,
any veterinarians that
are in the system.
We can go ahead and add
additional information,
as well.
You can actually
interact with the system
in multiple different ways.
And the net result here
is, in the case of Zipkin,
and we can go ahead and
look for any traces that
are coming into the system.
We can do this by service name.
So for example,
maybe I'll go ahead
and go take a look
at Discovery service
and see that there are actually
traces coming into the system.
And we can actually
drill into these
and see a variety
of different calls
are being made and
associated metadata.
We can actually see this is
coming from the OpenTelemetry
project, as well.
Now, I've actually
modified the collector
to also send to the
signal effects back end.
So here's another example where,
again, the data is being sent
to two different back ends.
So I can actually compare,
or I can send different datas
to different back ends.
Really, OpenTelemetry is
looking to be vendor agnostic
and provide a generic way
of handling instrumentation
for you so you can do
it once and not have
to worry about it afterwards.
So exact same data here.
As you can see, you
get a visual topology.
This basically represents what
we saw in the architecture
diagram of the GitHub repo.
And as you can see, I made no
Java changes in order to get
this instrumentation and
actually get some rich insights
both from a visual topology
perspective as well as my RED
metrics-- request,
error, and duration--
and any other metadata
that's associated with it.
So it's a very quick
demo on how you
can get started with
OpenTelemetry, both the auto
instrumentation
and the collector.
And without making any
code modifications, only
runtime parameters, we're able
to get some rich telemetry
data out of our application.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Thanks
for the demo, Steve.
As I mentioned at
the beginning, there
are already companies and groups
that are using OpenTelemetry
in production services today.
Google is one of them.
Starting back in
January, we actually
deployed the
OpenTelemetry collector
into instances of
Google Kubernetes Engine
versions 1.16 and above.
The OpenTelemetry
collector since then
has formed the backbone of the
metrics pipeline inside of GKE
and replaced a number
of deprecated components
like Heapster.
Similarly, we'll be
using OpenTelemetry
for CloudOps customers,
particularly Cloud Monitoring
Cloud Trace, to replace the
existing OpenCensus based SDKs
that they use to capture
application metrics, custom
metrics, and distributed traces.
Next, we're going to be using
open symmetry inside of Google
Compute Engine.
Have a new windows
system monitoring agent
that's actually based on
the OpenTelemetry collector
using a lot of the monitoring
system metrics capabilities
I talked about during
the introduction.
Beyond this, we'll be
using the collector
to replace our Linux monitoring
agent probably later this year
or early next
year, and that will
bring in the same
capabilities that we're
bringing to Windows right now.
At that point, I think
effectively all of our metrics
and tracing stack will be
moved over to OpenTelemetry,
at least when it comes to
capturing data from customers'
applications.
STEVE FLANDERS: At Splunk, we're
also leveraging OpenTelemetry
extensively.
We've basically
had this broken up
into two different
categories of work.
Internally we want
to actually consume
and leverage OpenTelemetry
as much as possible.
So in the case of
SignalFX and Omnition,
all of the infrastructure today
is leveraging the OpenTelemetry
collector in order to
collect both metrics
and trace information.
We're actually actively
underway moving
to OpenTelemetry client
libraries as well in order
to get rich insights and
move to an open source vendor
agnostic and open standard way
of gathering telemetry data
from our own environments.
Externally, we are active
contributors to the project.
We're actually maintainers
of the collector
as well as the Java
auto instrumentation,
and we're working very
closely with the community
to donate some of the SignalFX
open source components
around the smart agent, gateway,
and other auto instrumentation
semantic conventions
we've been working on.
Finally, we're about to get
kicked off with the .net auto
instrumentation sig.
So if you're interested
in that and really want
to get involved, we'd
love to have your help.
All right, next up, let's hear
from Francis about how Shopify
is leveraging OpenTelemetry.
FRANCIS BOGSANYL: Shopify is
partway through a migration
from a custom trace collection
infrastructure to one based
heavily around OpenTelemetry.
In addition, Shopify is
one of the maintainers
of the OpenTelemetry
Ruby client library.
At present, our architecture
looks like this.
We have a large number
of trace services
written in several languages and
instrumented in different ways.
Some of these are
externally developed,
such as [INAUDIBLE] and NGINX.
Some use our custom
instrumentation and export
in its custom format.
Some export in Jaeger's
format, some in OpenCensus,
some in Zipkin.
The OpenTelemetry collector is
the core of our architecture.
We add a couple of
components to it,
in particular a receiver
for our custom trace
format and our custom exporter.
Our use cases for the collector
include PII redaction,
down sampling for cost
control, adding tags required
by vendors, renaming spans
to control cardinality,
and fixing
instrumentation flaws.
Here's an example of PII
reduction in the collector,
focusing mainly on
database queries attached
to spans by the
instrumentation but also
with app-specific redaction.
At the top, we redact any
database statement tags
unless the span also
explicitly indicates
that no PII is present.
While we're down, we
identified that PII
can leak into the job
args tag for this service,
so we explicitly
redact those tags.
STEVE FLANDERS: So you just
heard from a cloud provider,
Google, a vendor,
Splunk, and an end user,
Shopify, about different
experiences leveraging
OpenTelemetry.
As you can see, there is broad
support and broad interest
in this topic.
In fact, OpenTelemetry has
the second most contributions
in all of CNCF behind
only Kubernetes.
That's pretty exciting.
And we would love to
have you come join us.
You can get involved in
the conversation on Gitter,
you can come join a special
interest group depending
on which area you
care most about,
and there are tons of great
issues both with help wanted
and good first issue
labels to get you started.
Please come join the community.
Please come join the discussion.
As Morgan mentioned,
we're just getting started
with the logging specification.
So if you're
interested in logging,
now's a great time to get
involved in that, as well.
We would love to have you
be part of the solution
to this important problem
for the industry as a whole.
And with that, thank you
so much for joining us.
We really appreciate
it and we hope
to see you in the
OpenTelemetry community soon.